that's a wrap for ea's press conference
here at e3 2015 and we are going to
round it up with our three highlights I
think we are all pretty much an
agreement of the games we really enjoyed
their mirrors edge Mass Effect and star
wars battlefront let's start uh I don't
know at the start I guess yeah matter of
fact let's go for its Mass Effect
Andromeda revealed in a trailer right at
the beginning if you know it's like in
the pre sure we said I drove it about
five times I think that is a
conservative estimate you guys we're
saying that for a long time but yes
there it is we got a glimpse at a sort
of a mass effect n7 character swiping
through a bunch of concept art but this
actually looks like it's I mean it's a
teaser trailer right but this is sort of
transitions into the navigation module
yeah and then I think those are the
concept worlds that we got to see last
year as well when they were showing
conceptual prototypes of the world they
were kind of creating and one of them
had a sky whale or just some giant
creature floating through space so
definitely gonna see some new creatures
in action of course I love a redesign of
the n7 armor I gotta say it looks kind
of it looks more alien if anything how
so I don't know just the way it's
jutting out and not entirely conforming
to the shape of whatever new Shepherd is
you get a glimpse of it yeah and
actually so in that moment sort of the
jetpack scramble and now in this moment
coming up the armor does look there's
sort of a more nimble kind of gameplay I
mean you know you can always run a
shepherd but this ground pound here
there's sort of it feels like a little
bit more of a kinetic focus on the
heroes mobility and in that pot as well
you could hear a Reaper sound effect
yeah when the building things were
moving um so maybe hinting because
everything does things like they can't
pull a Daleks on it and keep bringing
the Reapers back at every single
opportunity but I'd like to think there
was some kind of reaper influence some
kind of connection to the technology you
know because as we learn from the
Protheans and mass effect that old
technologies is kind of around
and has weird influences on the
different species of people that find it
always we didn't see any gameplay well
the holiday 2016 young yeah no I mean I
think I think we all thought or at least
hope that it was further along in
development and it was um I can wait I
can wait and it does look absolutely
beautiful yeah was that enough to give
you a little little weight you know like
okay it's coming looks pretty cool I'm
down we can just wait how about that
Mako or whatever the version of it that
there's that thing was quick that was
like creepy insects quick you know when
you see an insect moving like now you
shouldn't be able to do that should be
able to go that was fast it reminded me
a little of the because they did have
this speedy was it the firewalker in my
spec to it was a good DLC yeah like
thing and it was speedy but obviously it
was a float off the ground so this looks
like a best of both worlds or its tanky
and yet nimble very exciting Mass Effect
Andromeda that's our first look got it
just at the e a press conference here at
e3 2015 next up Mirror's Edge catalyst
we got to see some gameplay of that one
in action and it's not the whitewashed
red highlighted world necessarily the
sort of city seems to have been flushed
out aesthetically yeah I was actually
running a new story when when this was
on so I didn't as you get to see it so
guys could describe it for me just
describe it to for everyone well why
don't you look at this trailer now
alright well better yet yeah do you see
the kind of cues that are you know the
scuff marks the red walls that are sort
of visual cues to help you maintain your
speed that thing that made mirrors edge
so I like it made it you able to have
that kind of momentum through the world
of course we see some combat with faith
kicking some ass later on but uh the
woman presenting made mention that faith
doesn't use guns yeah and so doesn't
like use them but she use them interject
you could individually you could but you
also i think you were you were rewarded
if you did like a pacifist playthrough
and didn't use them at all so it's
interesting do you think they'll be
you'll be able to use them or is it's
just gonna go pure punchy kicky this
time around maybe she just hasn't
learned how to use them yet because you
can't you know just
mcgann and just or so Kenny they are
doing that slash and burn on the story
this there was a lot of different if
you've played the first Mirror's Edge I
won't say anything for spoilers but
there are a lot of small moments in this
trailer that sort of indicated to me
that we're getting a new look at the
story I think a reboot on the story you
like that you like getting a reboot I
think it seems smart yeah yeah um let's
talk a little bit about the fact that it
is now completely open yeah there are no
levels there's it's just complete free
roam no loading screens Wow like wow
that's that's the real I mean I really
incredible right so you think about sort
of an open world right and then okay but
then how do you sort of gate players
progress because there's always some
kind of mechanic whether the enemies in
a certain area are just too formidable
or whether you need to get to a certain
story beat to unlock this area so you
can imagine that it's just because it's
an open world doesn't mean you can go
everywhere right from the start but it
certainly implies a kind of freedom yeah
and broad sort of uh what's the word
that you know like options in terms of
way you can approach a given situation
I'd say that was what the dream of the
original game at least right you wanted
that level of freedom and I think it's
really commendable that EA are trying
their best and rebooting this franchise
I think a lot of people love the
original Mirror's Edge didn't kind of
fell short a little bit in terms of
critical response and sales but so I
think they're doing a great job in just
trying to restore it I think it's good
yeah keeping the visual identity and
sort of the aesthetic identity but then
also giving nods that yeah this is a new
take on mirrors edge for a new
generation of consoles that's Mirror's
Edge catalyst shown off the e a press
conference here at e3 2015 and then of
course the e a press conference ended
with star wars battlefront as promised
chitra house said it right from the
beginning and we've known we were going
to get gameplay ever since the reveal
and lo and behold the battle on ice
Planet pause I was actually traveling
throughout the whole thing it was so
good I mean everything about it was
exceptional I loved it so much alright
give me give me one thing about it it
was stood out in particular I think it
was the scope of the battle so you could
you could go into 80 80 s or at
we want to pronounce 8080 to Wikipedia
okay we talked about earlier then what
do you call 80s all right the thing we
are not arguing Star Wars Canon here
does not that you go down that rabbit
hole no not canon anyway yes you can
just flying in ship's commanding
different vehicles having Jedi powers
seeing Darth Vader on the battlefield
just everything about it I I thought
they absolutely nailed than them I just
I can't wait to play this game it looks
incredible it's a beautiful-looking game
this is the impression I got when we got
to see the gameplay demo at Star Wars
Celebration was just the environmental
detail was rich like look at the the
stuff on the rocks since that kind of
detailing really pops in a way that it
doesn't feel distracting it just feels
enriching to the whole environment all
those footprints in the snow so they
said that dice have been working with a
process called photogrammetry yes which
is just basically you take a buttload of
photos of something like a cliff face
and then feed it into a program and it
spits out these really realistic looking
models you can just plunk straight into
the game and it's clear that it just
like it's helping the game look fun time
yeah it's such it's such a great
development tool and I guess more games
gonna be using it now um but it's just
the whole game it just looks great it
looks so good and we saw some vehicles
in action here of course a TIE fighter
there's also x-wing flight these of
course are only in atmosphere they've
announced that there are no space
battles in Star Wars Battlefront also I
think I misspoke on the pre-show 40
players is the is the cap that they were
not for 32 that I mentioned so 20 per
side but yeah like and the changing of
perspectives right between third person
first person I hope and out of ship view
just incredible and they do that in a
ship they do that in the 8080 they do
that at and you do that on foot and you
can do that at will at any point in time
depending on how you prefer to play or
what this what you think will give you a
situational advantage or if you just in
this as in this case want to take a look
at your sick green mohawk yeah yeah oh
we're come here to like this was my
favorite moment I think just when the
guy turns around and justly that his
buddy its just oh yeah we're coming
no one of those nicely scripted moments
but yeah so you the shield moment was
really cool sound effects yep and that's
you know part of the sort of before
character class customization oh you're
right having a neck problem oh look is
so fanservice and I just love it look at
that pout they've got going oh yeah
that's that's full-on turtleneck
Skywalker's writing I like that battle
friend is letting you I know a lot of
people are like oh like it breaks the
immersion if you have either in the
battlefield you know what I like playing
with cannon whirls could you do this
running up to him but soon this is such
a great moment absolutely yes duty with
excitement though playing as those here
a hero characters definitely something
in battle fronts history that's been
wonderful they're bringing it back in a
big way I and battle fronts coming out
this fall yeah as excited horse one week
after fallout in Tomb Raider gonna be a
busy mom yeah uh embarrassment of riches
hopefully as all these games turn out to
be as exciting as we're hoping they will
be thank you folks so much for joining
us for our EA post conference pre and
post-show coming up next is the Ubisoft
press conference in just about 20
minutes we're gonna take a break and
we're going to be back to stream that
press conference to you live and we back
with a post-show analysis following to
talk about all the highlights they're
all the stuff they hit all the new IP
they hopefully unveil and more
excitement here from e3 2015
you